pausa en el vídeo y traten de calcular
cuánto es 27 1 y también si es posible
cálculo en cuanto es 27 10 vamos a
resolverlo juntos creo que esta primera
es bastante fácil de calcular ya que si
estamos agregando una unidad tendremos
el siguiente número más grande y de 27
pasaremos a 28 pero la razón por la que
estamos haciendo este ejercicio es para
pensar detenidamente en las posiciones
de valor aquí el número 27 tiene un 2 en
la posición de las decenas y tiene un 7
en la posición de las unidades así que
podemos visualizar el número 27 como dos
decenas aquí tenemos dos grupos de diez
y siete unidades que tenemos aquí y si
sumo una unidad más aquí tenemos una
unidad más con que nos vamos a quedar
seguiremos teniendo dos decenas pero
cuántas unidades vamos a tener una dos
tres cuatro cinco seis siete y ocho ocho
unidades
nos quedará 28 y esto quizá no lo
sorprenda pero es importante que
pensemos en esto en términos de las
posiciones de valor ya que más adelante
nos va a ser muy útil
conforme aprendamos más matemáticas
ahora hagamos lo mismo con 27 10 ya
dijimos que 27 es 2 decenas y 7 unidades
y ahora el 10 vemos que el 1 está en la
posición de las decenas ya no se
encuentra en la posición de las unidades
que representaba una unidad ahora está
en la posición de las decenas por lo que
representa un grupo de diez una decena y
tenemos cero unidades si sumamos estas
juntas que nos va a dar ahora tendremos
una dos tres decenas un tres en la
posición de las decenas y vamos a seguir
teniendo siete unidades 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
siete unidades noten que cuando aquí
agregamos el 1 incrementamos la posición
de las unidades en 1 y aquí cuando
sumamos 10 que realmente es una decena
no incrementamos la posición de las
unidades e incrementamos la posición de
las decenas